الكلام نذهب الان الى احمد فالول ولد
الدين ومعه ايضا نتابع هذه الساعات الاولى
ونرصد معه جمله التطورات احمد
نعم عبد القادر انا اقف وسط مكان اختراعي
هي ثانويه تسمى ثانويه كمال اتاتورك
جدا يمكن ان نقول بانه كبير على هذا
المكان بالذات لاحظنا انه كما اشار
الزملاء يتم بطريقه سريعه جدا فما هي الا
ورقه واحده على المقتنع ان يختار فيها بين
الرجلين المرشحين للرئاسه عبد القادر
نتذكر ان هذه المدينه يوجد فيها تنافس حاد
بين الاتجاهين بين مرشح تحالف الجمهور رجب
طيب اردوغان ومرشحه تحالف الشعب كمالك
الاشجار مع ان هذه المدينه تقليديا على
الاقل منذ 85 تميل لصالح الحزب الشعب منذ
99 ويسيطر عليها حزب الشعب سيطره كامله
هذه المدينه عبد القادر رغم ذلك فيها
تنافس بين الرجلين حيث ان كمال الاجدار
اوغلو يحاول اقناع الطبقه التي تصوتت
المرشح سنان اوغان في الدوره الاولى كي
تصوت له وهي حوالي خمسه بالمئه في مدينه
في منطقه ازمير اقناعها حتى انه في احد
اطلالاته قبل الصمت الانتخابي طالب صراحه
اما ان تصويت لي او ان تجلسوا في بيوتكم
وتقاطعوا الانتخابات حرصا منه على هذه
النسبه في كافه تركيا وفي هذه المدينه
بالذات التي تمثل رمزيه خاصه بالنسبه لحزب
الشعب باعتبارها القلعه
التقليديه لحزب الشعب طبعا في هذه المدينه
هناك عشره الاف صندوق
سيصوت بها ثلاث ملايين ونصف ناخب ليحددوا
طبيعه وجهه وهويته من سيحكمه تركيا خلال
السنوات الخمس القادمه من خلال حديث عبد
القادر مع بعض
الناخبين ومع بعض المسؤولين هنا لمست ان
حزب العداله والتنميه حاول بدل جهدا كبيرا
خلال فتره من فتره الماضيه لكي يكسر الهوى
الهائله بينه وبين حزب الشعب فقد اعطت
ازمير المرشح كماله الجدار اكثر من 60% من
الجوله الاولى 63 فاصل في الجوله الاولى
بينما اعطت الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان واحدا
وثلاثين بالمئه وعليه حزب تحالف الجمهور
ايضا بدوره يحاول اقناع هذه الفئه التي في
الوسط فئه القوميين ومن ينصف بعضهم
بالمتطرفين القوميين حتى يعطوا اصواتهم
للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بدل التصويت لحزب
الشعب التصويت يمر على قدم الوثائق بطريقه
طبيعيه جدا تستطيع ان ترى الناس يدخلونها
ويخرجون لم نلاحظ اي مشكله ابدا مع ان
المشاعر حاده في هذه المدينه حسب ما فهمنا
من كل احاديثنا مع الناس مواقفهم حاده جدا
سواء كانوا المصوتين للتحالف الشعب او
تحالف الجمهور طبعا هذه المدينه كما اسلفت
عبد القادر رمزيتها عاليه ولذلك
[ضحك]
في الجوله الاولى لصالح سنان اوغان هذه هي
التي يتنافس عليها الرجلان من اجل ان
يحاول احدهما زياده منسوبه في هذه المدينه
وعليه كما اسلفت
التصويت يسير على قدم الوسائق الامور
الطبيعيه جدا سريع الانتخاب السريع
لاحظنا وجود كبار السن والشباب ايضا حتى
منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى وما علينا الا ان
ننتظر ماذا ستقوله العشره الاف الصندوق
عبد القادر بعد الساعه الخامسه مساء